I wrote my vows what you did wait to do
that answer that chick with the big ass
dude did you write your vows while you
still had like stripper glitter on the
clothes I'm sure you didn't write your
vows to the stripper you wrote them
drunk Wow they're my bag right now give
me that bag right now
we call that the douche bag
[Laughter]
if JD's fiance is listening turn off
your radio now go get your juice bag and
let me hear this [ __ ] speech all
right he's going on and don't bust this
guy's balls I got to make sure he says
the right thing writing right after this
trip how many words into this is it
gonna be I don't know he might have
something because I think he was all sex
stuff from the strip club all right go
ahead I love you so much you are a
beautiful creature yeah I'm trying to
read it just just read it and be
uninhibited I am I have to understand a
first I can't imagine my life without
you
I'm crying because you mean so much to
me I want to make you happy you're so
beautiful and sweet we have so much fun
I don't want that I don't want it to end
I hope you don't still marry me I love
you first of all you scratching that
word creature you don't call your wife a
creature okay every sentence starts the
same way every sentence has no more than
five words fifth grader wrote that I was
drunk of course it's not like the
greatest look so much but we I hope it
doesn't end nothing personal about the
vows
what do you say about your wife there
that you couldn't generically get out of
a hallmark any woman now to read me the
first sentence again and I'm gonna help
you oh I love you so much okay what do
you love about her she's very beautiful
I love her personality she's very
outgoing and my
my darling I love you so much I love
your personality and I love your beauty
inside and out
that's already it's been improved okay
Jesus Christ I never heard [ __ ] hey we
just got from the strip I'm good with
the creature thing innit I wanna hear
you are a beautiful creature I'll change
at the you know you're a beautiful woman
you don't need you're a beautiful woman
you just told her in the first sentence
she's beautiful
what about her is beautiful specifically
I love her eyes she has beautiful eyes
what color are her eyes green okay
pretty sure so we're gonna start the
sentence where we go darling when I
stare into your green eyes what happens
to emotionally when you're looking
through green eyes oh she looks at me I
feel good how about this you are a
beautiful green eyed woman and I am a
disgusting creature
the next sentence I can't imagine my
life without you
you had [ __ ] 30 years of a life
without her that's not it
how about something positive I want you
to listen to me I'll help you I want you
in my life forever
yes that's what I mean we'll say what
you [ __ ] mean come on come on what's
the thing you love in life most like
like besides stove top stuffing or even
that you could say if you were if you if
I love you like stove top stuffing
that's American too
you gotta say what you love about her
thought it would be interesting to see
what I can read the rest of that to me
again I was crying I said I'm crying
because you mean so much to me I'm
crying because you mean so much to me
yes you mean more than the golden
archers if you were a Sam with that
would be filet-o-fish
you want a shiny spoon in my spoon color
okay that's the core of some very like
kind of cave mannish type thoughts yes
now you got to go back and be specific
about her be human about that's all I'm
saying
smile mean to you I just said anything
you like you light up my life like makes
you feel good her eyes make you feel
good or smile okay doesn't mean anything
what I mean I mean something you but it
means something to me no it does no it
doesn't but you're not putting it off I
got a personalized it okay what's the
last sentence something about it I hope
you will still marry me I hope you don't
know what do you make it you're ending
with a joke I don't know what that mean
I don't know why did you write that what
do you think you don't know what that
means
I maybe because I I thought this is
shiny or something I don't know you're
making a negative out of the whole
wedding
I hope he will still marry me she's in
the middle of marrying and let's talk
about something else Howard what is a
vow a vow is like I promise to prop you
up when you're down calm one vow in that
entire thing angry I think I got it I
vow to be an ear to listen to you I vow
to be faithful I vow to hold you above
all others
you got no don't say that say I don't
have [ __ ] for brains I gotta get this
thing together I am and you know what
kills me with this guy he considers
himself a writer who is one day gonna
write a movie are you [ __ ] kidding
right goodbye you're lacking I'm helping
you right now where are you going just
tell me where you're going why you am i
not helping you I'm done why are you
done I don't understand I just don't
I'm bi that just annoys me what annoys
you mean thing know who is you in this
room here is annoying you don't think I
help you right now is this why none of
us were invited to the wedding
[Laughter]